[Applause]
[Music]
Ireland the country with the highest
density of famous musicians per capita
in the entire world
island in the country with less than 5
million inhabitants even Boston has a
larger population but as small as the
population may be Island is the cradle
of well-known music like any of the
cranberries and of course bono for
beauty
so there's another thing that makes
Ireland famous as well and laughs that
it's the second wealthiest country in
the eurozone further Irish people have
more money than the British or even the
Swiss and this is the private given that
just 30 years ago Ireland was as poor as
Greece yep you heard that right back
then one in every five Irish University
students were emigrating to other
country today there are more people with
Irish blood living in the US or
Australia than there are in Ireland
itself nonetheless now this country is
home to some of the world's leading
technological companies firms like Apple
or Google have their tax headquarters
there and many of you might be thinking
now that that's simply because of the
low taxes there right now of course it
is absolutely true that Island does
offer good fiscal conditions for
companies but other countries like the
Republic of Liberia or the Seychelles
also offer pretty low corporate taxes
and then also even half as rich as
honest
so the big question here is what have
they done to grow so fast how is it that
even after the financial crisis island
remains wealthier than Switzerland today
we're going to answer this question but
first as usual we're going to take a
look at the history the poorest of the
wealthiest Islands was born in 1922 but
before that the whole island was part of
the British crown and the relationship
well it wasn't exactly great for the
English politicians Ireland was a land
of Catholic peasants who were unwilling
to work and devoted to having lots and
lots of children
this explains why after they got their
independence the New Republic of Ireland
cut all of their ties with London well
actually it wasn't just London they
closed off their relationships with the
rest of the world as well
even during World War two they were the
only english-speaking country that
captain neutral but not only that the
different Irish governments closed their
gates to international trade they even
put a ban on foreigners owning or
investing in local companies so now the
question is what would the outcome of
all of these policies well well so that
would be a brutal economic crisis
fortunately enough because Irish people
spoke English they can easily move to
the United States we're not talking
about adventurers
[Music]
in just a few decades the Irish
population reduced by half and of course
the national industry never grew as it
was expected to think about it in such a
small country it is impossible to find
the tools and resources needed to build
factories and machines which just isn't
enough industry they needed to import
them but because the government put so
many fairs and barriers to foreign trade
it was pretty hard to get the material
needed to certain new company this was
why in 1957 the government of Shawn
Thomas O'Kelly made Island turn 180 on
their trade policy this is how they went
from not buying anything through opening
their gates to the entire world
[Music]
right after that they signed a free
trade agreement with the UK in the
decade later they would enter the
European community which later came to
be called the European Union but hold on
just a minute my dear libertarians who
might be watching this video just hold
back your enthusiasm for a wee moment
because this openness to free trade
we're not exactly a good as expected
[Music]
think about it for decades Ireland was
closed for business
they had nationalized many of their
companies and the company knows that
they have no rivals and their market
share is guaranteed by the government
they have very little reason to improve
this explains for instance why in 1980
people in the city of cork which is in
the southern part of Ireland had so many
electricity breakdowns and brownouts
their wiring network hadn't been
replaced for decades the same happened
in many other industries and now all of
a sudden the Irish economy allows people
to buy goods abroad new product more
competitive products they appeared in
the market so now you're probably
wondering what happens to those local
producers well unsurprisingly they
disappeared and wisdom thousands of
people just lost their jobs in 1987
Ireland reached an unemployment rate of
17% so once again the Irish youth
started packing up and moving abroad
[Music]
now if you've been following visual
politics for some time you'll probably
know that immigration isn't really much
of a problem for a country can you guess
what the real issue is well actually
it's exactly the opposite migration we
need to consider is who is leaving
Ireland well it was the University
student so it was those people with
higher skills this caused what is known
as a brain drain
[Music]
oh but believe me there's more than this
in order to attract multinational
corporations the government lowered
taxes and of course this strategy worked
out well so it's like Intel Apple
Microsoft they chose Ireland as the
place for their European headquarters so
named over wondering what's the
following with us this sounds great
well they essentially just opened up a
tiny office with an accountant
this means that their contribution to
the country's wealth was actually fairly
poor if this was not enough the same
government that put the red carpet out
to companies was also raising income tax
on its citizens some people ended up
paying 60% in tax from their salaries if
this was not enough Irish legislation
did not make it easy to hire people so
now consider the situation jobs are
disappearing local companies are going
bankrupt government spending is on the
rise and thousands of Irish people are
just leaving the country in 1988 The
Economist magazine published this
article
most of the rich poor island behaved as
though it was rich now it must pay the
price
alright alright alright so that's the
bad stock of it now how did they step
out of this scenario well let me tell
you a story
[Music]
the Celtic Tiger roars it was the year
1987 and Charles Haughey had won the
elections in Ireland he found a country
on the edge of collapse and he realized
something you can't open your economic
system without first modernizing it of
course companies like Oracle or HP were
happy to be in Ireland and pay less
taxes and they were paying in the US but
were they willing to open a Research
Center or a factory that would employ a
thousand people the answer was no and
why well firstly we have to deal with
the labor laws which were a bureaucratic
nightmare but not only that remember we
said about the 60% income tax this means
that no matter how high the salaries for
the worker were a fairly large chunk of
that is still going to the government
[Music]
in other words highly skilled
professionals with rather different
means for the United States so the first
policy implemented by Jorge was to deal
with trade unions the companies salaries
would grow at the same rate and the
economy would on the other hand he
lowered income taxes this way work has
ended up making more money even if the
wages were the same and this soon
started generating results Packard Lakes
wit plant is to employ 2,000 people by
the year 2000 in a short amount of time
all of those multinational companies
that had opened their fiscal
headquarters on Irish soil started
owning their own factories and offices
meanwhile unemployment with going down
wages were on the rise and even the
government collected more money but not
only that this deal with the unions and
bureaucratic simplification helps create
all new companies
[Music]
the other slang with Ryanair bought the
t-shirt at Primark drunken Guinness well
all of these companies expanded
internationally during those years this
explains why the Irish economy grew as
much as the Chinese economy during the
1990s suddenly addresses in Dublin would
offer champagne to their customers some
people even flew to New York to do
shopping on the weekends these were the
years of the Celtic Tiger and the last
points the economists decided to
dedicate another article to the country
a decade ago Irish incomes with less
than two-thirds of Perdition comes last
year by one measure they had surpassed
prediction comes there hold on just a
moment because not everything in so
perfect of course during those 15 years
salaries doubled but that optimism drove
banks to offer mortgages to nearly
everyone and encourage ridiculous
spending in those years there were even
companies that rented helicopters for
children to have their first communion
in the air and this led to a financial
crisis that we are going to cover in
another video if you don't want to miss
that video please do not forget to
subscribe to this channel meanwhile you
might want to watch another video where
we explain why London is actually
growing faster than New York City you
can click here to see it
[Music]
so now the question is do you think that
the Irish model could help other
countries like Greece or perhaps India
do you think poor countries could
benefit from attracting foreign
investment you can leave your arms first
in the comments below we would love to
read it and if you did like this video
please do give us a thumbs up below and
other ways I'll see you in the next one
and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at Lee consider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]